lo afecta fundamentalmente en la
seguridad militar en la respuesta contra
las organizaciones
islamistas yihadistas y el malí se había
convertido en el la cueva de donde
salían todas todas las amenazas y era el
cuartel general de las de las
operaciones de al qaeda en el sahel y
desde luego
retirar las tropas militares sin
un relevo en la en la misión afecta
extraordinariamente a la lucha
geopolítica en la región y desde luego
automáticamente se va a reforzar
afortunadamente lo que se va a producir
es un traslado de fuerzas y ponderar la
presencia tanto de francia de los
soldados franceses como de otros países
europeos en los países ribereños y de
hecho que buena parte de las de las
tropas que hoy están en malí van a estar
en níger en seis meses dando respuesta a
esta demanda de seguridad y es
estratégica para europa macrón dice que
en gran parte la retirada se debe a que
no hay cooperación de la junta militar
que gobierna mal y puede haber efectos
positivos de esta decisión de retirada
para ambas partes
no no va a haber un efecto positivo al
contrario lo que se va a ver es un
refuerzo de la presencia
fundamentalmente de rusia en el mal el
problema fundamental que hay en lo que
se ha producido el cambio sustancial es
que se ha producido en los últimos siete
años es que fueron las autoridades de
malí quien pidió ayuda a la antigua
metrópoli colonial que era que era
francia y en ese momento el presidente
francés decidió mandar a organizar esta
misión que no solamente en francesa sino
también en otros países europeos en los
últimos dos años ha habido dos golpes de
estado en el malí que han cambiado
totalmente la clase política y sobre
todo las prometidas elecciones no se han
celebrado
relaciones no es que fueran hayan ido a
mal haya ido a peor sino que han sido
catastróficas de hecho las autoridades
militares de madrid expulsaron al propio
embajador francés el 30 de enero
consecuencia es al borde de una ruptura
diplomática entre las partes
lo que nos encontramos en este momento
es la sustitución de buena parte del
nivel máximo de seguridad de mali de las
tropas francesas a la compañía va a ser
de mercenarios rusos esto es un cambio
de geopolítica y
rusia tratando de incrementar su peso
estratégico el mal bueno y pasando al
otro tema que compromiso se pueden
esperar de la cumbre que mantienen la
unión africana y la unión europea en
bruselas
fundamentalmente lo que se va a hablar
es de seguridad y de cooperación
económica es decir te ayuda al
desarrollo por parte de europa hacia los
países
africanos en general aquí también hay
una competencia geopolítica de gran
magnitud hace menos de dos años una
cumbre semejante entre china y el país
el de la unión africana reunió a más
líderes africanos que los que hoy están
en bruselas es decir para los para los
grandes dirigentes políticos
africanos es más atractiva la
cooperación con china con la unión
europea fundamentalmente porque la unión
europea exige unos unos unos avales en
derechos humanos que china en absoluto
pide pero de aquí lo que se va a ver es
un incremento de la presencia
fundamentalmente de ayuda al desarrollo
de europa en áfrica señor sepúlveda
muchas gracias por su análisis y por
compartirlo con nosotros en france24